well every day more and more people are
turning to social media to express their
talents and for two local women being an
influencer is a dream and pays the bills
christian casadas explains how they're
making some big profits by generating
online buzz
doing hair is definitely a full-time job
you fall in love with your clients and
you eat sleep and live your clients you
become the brand i am the walking beauty
brand it's a new age of business and
damien flagler says she is embracing it
her hair styling company is growing
thanks to social media i believe my
platform grew from the transformations
of my clients with over 400 thousand
instagram followers this influencer's
average day at work is not your typical
nine to five this is my full-time job um
this is not part-time you are fully
indebted into
your clients they dictate your life you
want them to be happy you want them to
look good according to instagram
planning and scheduling tool hopper hq
athletes and celebrities are some of the
highest influencers earning about 1.6
million bucks per post it's a key focus
for dj money who says while social media
is important traditional marketing such
as using billboards shouldn't be ignored
being a dj definitely here in las vegas
absolutely provides a steady income
people are always coming here to party
or create an experience so there's never
a shortage of gig
according to this online tool a regular
youtuber earns about seven dollars and
sixty cents per 1000 views while google
keeps 45
of the revenue the combination of
followers views and sponsorships is what
brings in the cash i like to party i
like to have a good time and i really
just created the environment that i
wanted to experience so here we go the
secret according to this online agency
is simple first understand your audience
and create a unique profile interact
with your followers be consistent and
promote
a tactic these two influencers have
nailed as they continue to ride the
social media wave with thousands
following their every step i definitely
think that there's a shift in regards to
people becoming entrepreneurs especially
via social media
it's one of the biggest trends right now
between tick tock and instagram youtube
influencing um so i definitely think
it's going to be you know something that
really really grows as the years go by
christian casa is live local now
both of those influencers tell us the
secret to their growing success online
is finding that passion within having
patience and then just sharing it with
the world